i want to talk about uh manipulation of
propaganda yeah if we can so i have this
uh this tweet from me
you are being played they are
manipulating your emotions to get you to
support war
in the first clip you can see emotional
moment german interpreter cries during
zelinski's speech then you have this
tweet cnn interpreter cries as he
translates zelinski's speech that
mentions children killed by russian
strikes
and then you have another story
translator breaks down during photo
mirrors olenski speech to european
parliament i i do believe it's not uh i
believe it's two interpreters but i
posted these three stories because of
the ones i just happened to have um my
my intent to what to explain here is
not so much that there are uh there are
two different circumstances i found
where translators began crying that is
wholly inappropriate in my opinion and i
believe it's propaganda and manipulation
not necessarily intentional or whatever
but i think they allow these things to
happen they they know these things are
going to happen because what they want
is
when the president of ukraine is giving
a speech talking about the devastation
and uh speaking
literally about what's happening
children are dying we need to push back
on this
to drive the point home in terms of
manipulating emotions you have someone
cry while saying it which the president
of ukraine certainly was not doing
this is a manipulation of your emotions
to hear someone
so you go oh no they're crying
they want you to support ground war in
ukraine and why
why
i mean well this comes back to what i'm
saying right well why would you want to
do that
military industrial complex prophets no
but you know it's going to spark
i guess who's the they in the major
world region there's there i think for
me it's always a simple solution of who
benefits and it's um weapons
manufacturers uh stocks skyrocketed the
moment war was declared and you know it
and they they actually did that article
10 it was like digital security firms
like paladin's here
we there's an article that said um what
was it uh cutting russia off from the
swift payment system could result in
major cyber attacks here are some stocks
that will greatly improve or you know
will go up in value and it's like
basically saying invest in these
companies
so lydia what i've just done is i've
just emailed you the um the video that
i'm talking of of the azure fighters
doing that
i couldn't send you the tweet because
twitter has decided that this tweet
is it on your twitter no it's still on
twitter but you can't tweet it out you
can't retweet it or send it to somebody
but because i quote because i quote
tweeted it i've sent you my quotes okay
well who who posted it the the
international you quote so the national
uh guard of ukraine posted the video oh
this is the pig's blood one yeah yeah
i'm looking at it now yeah
yeah and so i because i quote tweet it i
can send you my quote tweet which allows
you but i couldn't send the actual when
did you post it uh on the um
27th of feb then maybe we can help
because i i'm did you
let me let me let me do this what did
you say in the quote tweet do you want
me to email it to you no no just tell me
what it was i can pull it up
i've said why does the national guard of
ukraine think it acceptable to glorify
the nazi as of brigade while they grease
bullets with lard
to target khadirov's chechen forces here
we are the easiest way to pull it up i'm
sorry your country was attacked me but
armed nazi units are not an answer
especially when pulling off this i i
gotta say i don't know if youtube would
uh consider it a violation of the rules
if we show that video but twitter did
but let's see the yeah twitter considers
a violation of the rules if you clicked
view you can see if you hit view the
video will come up because it's not been
banned
my concern is that youtube will delete
the livestream we should definitely show
this on the after show regardless yeah
we'll show it on the in fact we'll have
a conversation about religion and the
implications yes but uh this is one of
the problems of propaganda manipulation
and censorship and it's why they need
censorship i'm i i actually believe if
we were to show that video youtube would
probably just take the stream down give
us a strike block us from streaming yeah
because it's bad for the establishment
narrative and yet and yet it's
newsworthy to know that that's what the
formal ukrainian army has tweeted out
with our funding and backing hunter
biden's laptop was particularly
newsworthy
this is the first moment i've seen him
turn into a religious war of any type
yeah they're going after their faith
right and then why am i raising that's
the point why i'm raising this is
because those that new york times
article you pulled up to him right so
those fighters now let's call them
foreign fighters a bit like we called
foreign
fighters foreign fighters right they go
to join that battalion they've gone and
they know they're targeting chechen
muslims they get radicalized their nazis
they go back to france 10 of france is
muslim yeah
and france has its own muslim
radicalization problem and france as we
know and if you read any of welbeck for
example his book submission we know what
could potentially happen with that
tension and i worry that you end up with
this perfect storm
and you end up with a civil conflict in
europe and of course if you need to
build back better you need your great
reset you can't build back unless
there's unless there's a great reset
both of those phrases happen to come
from some
in the united states there's a
escalating concern of a civil conflict
here as well yeah and i i certainly feel
like it's um
like it's coming i saw a story of google
pay and apple pay uh banned russia they
don't you can't use it in russia to get
on the subway anymore so the lines are
really long so i was thinking the cost
the cost is not only fiscal but it's
time if you can't get to where you're
going in time then you can't get it done
in time which means it doesn't get done
right which is another kind of cost you
gotta that's right but let's push this a
bit right so
um who why would you have a policy of
divide and conquer in this way yeah why
do you want me hating you guys
right muslim hating non-muslims
if your is if your system is under
threat as we know from the british
empire
the best way to make sure that all of us
are not looking up
is to make sure we're looking left and
right
that's critical race theory correct
and that's what i believe if you look at
the situation with the money supply if
you look at like what's going on with um
this desire to to have this great reset
the only thing that makes sense is to
encourage everybody to turn on each
other and we witness that happening we
witness that happening in our media
narratives
you know there's a reason why the word
racism is now being thrown around
everywhere by not by you or me but by
big corporations
who you know you think about it what why
have they suddenly become so interested
in stoking these racial fires
what's going on and these are some of
the biggest profit making corporations
on the planet why why is the people who
were uh supporting the rise of our black
lives matter who then became the vaccine
mandate supporters are now the flag they
keep changing the emojis in their
twitter accounts and if you photos like
they're not they're they're not uh
independently thinking individual
prioritizing profit overall else maybe
but if you follow the causes they've
supported one thing you can see from
those causes is they all do end up
dividing everybody from each other to a
point where people are fighting each
other
yeah
rage bait why
hate clicks uh emotions put people in a
vulnerable place and then you can get
them do what you want them to do when
they're emotionally erratic a little
easier push this button now you better
and then you know i wonder if um
some people are just not able to be
independent thinkers that that's what i
should say some people are leaders some
people are followers there's nothing
wrong with being a follower some people
just want to you know get by and live an
honest life and have someone else be
more dedicated to the the hard decisions
i can understand that but if that's the
case that means there are a lot of
people who are going to say something as
absurd as
you know you you don't even got to do
anything you just look it up on the
cdc's website just do whatever they tell
you which in my opinion is an absurd
statement i mean you have to take some
responsibility for your own life when
you get a follower in a leadership
position like when someone says that
dumb follower mind but they have a
hundred thousand people listening to
them like they're leading follower leads
the followers then you get that's a good
it's a good example of of you know like
these uh these podcasters who have said
you don't even got to think about it
just do what the government tells you or
who have um
their followers who have been put in you
know high up positions where all they're
doing is telling their followers to
follow other people to do as they're
told basically because they themselves
are followers i think i think there's a
the the average person is working nine
to five who's struggling monday to
friday to put bread on the table for
them and their family
i can excuse them right they don't have
the time luxury or privilege to think
through some of these topics what i am
particularly animated about is those
people that do have the time luxury and
privilege to think through this stuff
and still choose to do
uh
still choose
a course of action that harms people
severely because they want to make money
and profit i know or well i i would say
there's also something else on top of
that i agree with you
but i would argue that in most
situations it's just the fact that they
don't want to think too hard about
things because then they face social
ostracism so if you're an academic and
you're out of line with the other
academics and question their orthodoxy
all of a sudden you're less likely to
get a promotion you're not getting
invited out and you're just not liked by
your friends which is really painful for
us as human beings so i think oftentimes
it isn't necessarily just a profit
motive it's about social status yeah
yeah yeah
it's funny that um
the people who throw on the word grifter
tend to be the grifters
it's projection isn't it because the
thief thinks everyone steals yeah you
get to compete well well let me let me
elaborate on this people base
people think everyone else
thinks and behaves the way they do
so what's interesting is you know i i
don't see you accusing left-wing
personnel as of being grifters um
i uh maybe uh periodically might say i
believe someone's ingenuous or grifting
but uh for the most part the uh
politically homeless the post-liberal uh
the freedom faction whatever you want to
call it aren't going around saying this
leftist personality is a grifter for
money
but the leftist personalities say it all
day every day they make shows and
segments just targeting people on the
opposite side of the political spectrum
and say they're grifting for money i
also i think it's a genuine failure to
understand human motivation in most
cases i think if somebody believes
something that they haven't really
looked deeply enough into to have a
fast-pace fact-based opinion on it's not
so much because they're trying to
cynically exploit people for gain that
can happen but i really think often
times it's because they settled on a
particular perspective they're afraid of
looking into it more deeply they do
believe that they're right and that
they're telling the truth but they're
not responsible in their pursuit of it
and so they end up promoting things they
shouldn't be promoting and saying things
that aren't true and they do end up
making money off of that but it's not as
if they're twirling their mustache going
i'm actually
a right winger and i'm making money as a
left-wing pundit or vice versa i i've
said something uh some uh something and
we saw um
who was it who said this uh i can't
remember the the gentleman's name i'm
forgetting clifton duncan sorry sorry
what's up uh i think it was clifton i
could be wrong um but i said something
the effect of you know the people who
know what's going on
they but they're but they're unwilling
to stand up and take responsibility and
do anything about it are part of the
problem but i believe it was clifton it
could be wrong if it wasn't forgive me
who said
that um he's starting to have more
contempt for those people that was close
than it was clifton yeah than which
people then the people who are just like
mindless drones is a part of the world
so the more contempt is for the ones who
know the ones who know but won't do
anything yeah well that's that's my
point you can't look
look you know people living on minimum
wage
people that are from say for example
migrant communities whose first language
is in english who are petrified that
they're going to get kicked out the
country if they step foot in the wrong
direction there are excuses and
understandable reasons for why people
may not be engaged with controversial
political conversation but there are
people that have the luxury and the
privilege to engage in that and either
don't say the right thing or are
actively saying and doing the wrong
thing and that's where i think the focus
needs to be go back to that example
and you've got governments and by
definition that means people in power
funding armed nazi brigades now what
that does immediately is undo the entire
last 12 years we put our we when i say
we now i'm talking about
muslims have put their neck on the line
to go and challenge a lot of the
extremism and terrorism that was coming
from our communities right we put our
neck on the line
me and the networks that i work with um
that one of them was going to come here
with me today but paperwork and whatever
uh usman my brother osman rajo we we do
a lot of um for example intervention
work in prisons with muslims who are
convicted of high-level terrorism
through mentoring through martial arts
to attempt to uh rehabilitate them now
you put your neck on the line for that
kind of work and you say to these people
that there is never an excuse for
example to leave your
democratic rights-based civil law based
country to go and join for example a
jihadi brigade in isis because you're
upset with assad that dictator right now
they're witnessing videos put out by
british media encouraging british
citizens to go to ukraine and join
that well that we just pulled up right
it's undone
all of the last 10 to 12 years and the
last point i'm making on this is that
back to that oceana discussion
like
we are so unaware of how that's
perceived outside of our media matrix
the work that's been undone is to the
point now where you're going to have a
16 year old muslim based in france who's
going to see those nazis go and fight
with other nazis and say you know what
why am i i'm going to go and join
the chechens and fight these guys
because they're dipping bullets in
pigslot we've gone back to square one i
was invited by youtube to an
anti-extremism event the concern was
that jihadi groups were using
youtube to recruit they were showing
videos they were claiming it was
injustice you to fight for justice and
they were talking about strategies to
stop this and it was particularly
particularly in the uk they said that
these groups were targeting kids in the
uk to convince them to go fight in these
wars i find it fascinating to bring up
now that it's effectively essentially
okay when it comes to ukraine well what
you've just said there right so i'm
going to pull uh something else up if my
if the wi-fi works heavy so if you if
you can pull that um tweet back up of
mine and go down it's a thread
so yeah scroll down
and uh
there will be
a um
oh oh you have to log in okay
so what what what so there's an
intercept article i can talk you through
it there's an intercept article
basically facebook on that point yeah on
radicalization
facebook has decided that it's
prohibited to promote the as of brigade
because they're neo-nazis
unless you're promoting them to fight
russia right in you i saw that that's
amazing isn't it now this is the what
i'm saying about the again i'm trying
not to swear right i'm doing the work
we've just done for 12 years on the
muslim side imagine you're a young you
know 16 year old french muslim right and
you see that imagine you're antifa you
were there man and you're and you're
screaming nazi for five years yeah and
then you're like finally we're getting
these people banned from facebook and
facebook goes whoa whoa whoa whoa we're
letting these guys back on i don't know
if people even know your history here it
is uh do you see that facebook allows
praise of neo-nazi ukrainian battalion
if it fights russian invasion wow
i mean i can send it to you lydia if you
want to put it up but that's amazing was
that on twitter that's on intercept oh
if you look if you look up the intercept
facebook allows praise of neo-nazi
ukrainian you'll get it on your screen i
just want people to see this tim forgive
me it's important because it's the
hypocrisy it stinks look at that that's
incredible
and the problem is whether you're antifa
or a young islamist right
the problem now is how are you going to
react to that yeah thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you